i just want to say how proud i am of you
for the documentary
for you being able to share
something
so personal
something that i didn't even know about
you didn't know i mean you never really
talked to me about it
when i was 16 we moved to new york and i
started sneaking out at night
ditching school and
my parents i got really scared
so they sent me to a boarding school
they didn't realize it was
pure torture camp
i
was
verbally
physically emotionally psychologically
and just abused on a daily basis
so what did you think when i was gone
i thought it was boarding school like i
was so young you know
couldn't do anything i couldn't tell my
parents
because these places manipulate the
parents just as much as they do the
children
anytime i bring it up with mom she's
like won't even talk about it she's like
i was scared you needed to go
i wasn't even doing anything i think
just because i'm their first daughter
and
moving to new york like being in la
having such a
strict
life it was very sheltered not able to
go anywhere
and then moving to new york all of a
sudden and living at the waldorf being
able to sneak out
and
get into every single nightclub in new
york and
be living the life of like a 21 year old
at 16
she was just scared
because
i would be terrified too like i think
about it now i'm like i understand why
they were scared because if i had a
daughter who was 16 and yeah she was
sneaking out and going to all these
places like i wouldn't want her around
that crowd or
any of that
so
even though i was mad that she was so
strict i feel like i'm gonna be the
strictest mom as well
i will no longer be silent and i'm gonna
use my voice and use my platform
and make a change and
be the hero that i needed when i was
there
it's so crazy i can't believe it's like
i even went through that it's like how
is that real life like
that's why i spoke up
if i didn't say anything like i don't
know who would
imagine if i just
held that in the rest of my life and
never said anything
probably would have been alone still i'm
single because i didn't want to let
anyone in or trust anyone i think that's
the most
important thing and of course that helps
so many people you know
talk to mom about it
um
no no they don't
really talk about it do you feel like
you got
closure from mom and dad
i feel like they just don't want to
think about it just like i didn't want
to think about it
didn't talk about it for 20 years so i
just
it's painful to think about to like open
that up
so
have you like
had to sit down just like
the three of you no
[Music]
i don't really know what to say
perhaps just like having that
conversation
just to
lay it out
just let them know how you feel
it's hard
yeah it's not like
they don't like talking about things
really
you know mom and his mom is just so fun
and like
chill and she doesn't really like to get
serious like i've never really had like
a serious like deep conversation about
things like that she's just
she doesn't like to think about bad
things she just likes to be happy
yeah
just how she is
i don't want to kill her vibe
no but that's
it could be
worth exploring
you know
one day
my parents feel bad and regret sending
me to provo but
i don't think that they really
understand what i went through because
they never watched the documentary so
they don't really know all the details
so i wish we could just one day just sit
down and have a real conversation
i just need to get the wedding plan
first i don't want to like cause any
drama before that
you know for so long since i was a
teenager i've really been just holding
all this in and
you know i'm about to get married and i
really just wish we could just
talk about it so i can just let it go
because i feel like i don't know if i'll
fully ever release this
unless we speak about it
you